-It is time to play a game
of deception called
"True Confessions."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-My first opponent tonight
is the host
of "Late Night
with Seth Meyers."
Please welcome Seth Meyers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow.
Smooth.
Smooth as silk.
What's that?
[ Both laugh ]
-I, uh -- I came --
-Wow. Smooth as silk.
-I came in
for rehearsal earlier.
-You really -- wow.
Oh, my God.
Seth Meyers with us.
Seth and I will be facing off
against a very talented actress.
Her new show,
"Kevin Can F Himself,"
airs Sundays at 9:00 p.m.,
on AMC.
Give it up for Annie Murphy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
All right, that's --
that's what I'm talking about.
That's what it's all about.
All right.
-Yes.
-Here we go!
All right.
Here's how this works.
In front of us are two envelopes
containing confessions.
One is true, the other is a lie.
Once you read your confession,
the other two players
get to interrogate you.
Then they have to --
You have to come up --
they have to come up with
a unanimous decision --
is it the truth or a lie?
-Mm.
-Seth, you will go first.
-Okay.
-What envelope should he open?
One or two?
What do you guys think?
[ Crowd shouts two ]
-Whoa! Unanimous two.
-They all said two, you know?
-Two.
-I quit Pop Warner Football
because we had to strip
to our underwear,
and I wasn't wearing any.
[ Laughter ]
-You quit Pop Warner because --
You're very athletic.
So I would say you did
play Pop -- what --
Did you play any other sports?
-Yeah.
I played baseball, sure.
Ran a little track.
-Uh, I have a question.
-Sure.
-Why were you not
wearing any underwear?
-I was in a rush
to get to Pop Warner Football.
[ Laughter ]
-Why were you in a rush?
-Yeah, why were you
in a rush that day?
-I was excited.
-How excited were you?
[ Laughter ]
-You guys,
this is about football.
-I know, of course it is!
Yeah.
You were excited.
You go, "I can't wait.
I'm going
to Pop Warner Football."
-Yeah.
-And you go to them, they go,
"Hey, we got to strip down so
you can get sized up."
-Yeah. They're like,
"We need to figure out
what size you guys are
for your pads."
-And Pop -- And Pop Warner is --
you're teenaged? No.
-Younger.
-Younger than that.
-12.
-12!
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Would you ever leave the house
with no underwear?
-I mean, I would say one out of
every five days I would.
[ Laughter ]
-What were you wearing?
-Jeans.
-Wow.
Jeans, no undies.
-Mm-hmm.
-Ouch!
-Yeah.
That's rough stuff there.
This is very interesting.
Because I feel like
you're so tricky
that you would make me believe
this whole thing about football.
Because I know you like sports.
-Yeah.
-So that would have me steer off
and believe
whatever story about sports.
-If I was lying,
that's exactly what I'd do.
[ Laughter ]
-I mean,
I don't know you at all.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-So this is --
-This could go either way, yeah.
-This could go either way.
This is difficult.
-I think --
I'm gonna say it's true.
Do you agree with me?
That he didn't have
any underwear?
-I think you're lying.
-Wait. You think he's lying?
-I think he's lying.
-Oh.
I'm gonna stick with Annie,
then.
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
-Well, we have to be unanimous.
-Oh, we have to be unanimous?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Oh, well, no.
That's is a lot of pressure.
-Yeah.
We think you're lying.
-Well, you're lucky Annie's here
because it's a lie.
-Ah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You saved me.
-I do want to --
-Yes.
What?
-It happened to my brother.
[ Laughter ]
-Is he okay?
-He's fine.
He left.
-Yes.
-And then I was also there
and had to play a whole year
of Pop Warner Football.
-All right.
All right, it's my turn.
Which one should I open?
One or two?
What do you think?
[ Crowd shouts one ]
How come two for Seth
and I get one?
All right, here we go.
Ready for this, bud?
When I was a kid,
I dreamt of being
a professional wrestler
called The Priest.
[ Laughter ]
-I think wrestlers are known
for having trademark moves.
What was The Priest's
trademark move?
-I had two trademark moves.
One was, I would --
I would put you in
a grapple hold, submission,
until you confessed a sin.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And so then I would know,
like, sins.
It was a good storyline,
you know?
-Sure.
-'Cause I'm a big fan of, uh --
Yeah, WWE.
WWF at the time.
My other move was,
if I body slam you,
and then I would pull out holy
water and bring you back to --
[ Laughter ]
I'd bring you back to life.
The Priest.
-Both very good.
-Uh, what did you wear?
-Uh, here's --
Well, I made it out of
cardboard, like poster board.
Like, the little --
the priest's, uh...
The thing.
-The collar.
-The collar. But I didn't
actually have a full-on uniform.
But if I did,
it would be that and a robe.
But then when I got in the ring,
I would take the robe off,
and I would have just the collar
and maybe two little things,
almost like a little
Chippendales dancer.
[ Laughter ]
-Ah.
-Play-out music?
-I was thinking cathedral organ.
[ Laughter ]
Like, full-on Church Lady.
-Yeah.
-Like -- yeah.
And it would go announce
that The Priest is here.
And I would come out
with incense.
[ Laughter ]
-Mm-hmm.
-Doing the thing.
And I think that people
would be totally into it.
Uh -- The Priest.
-Was this something you shared
with your friends?
I assume you watched wrestling
with friends your age.
Is this --
Did they know at the time
that you wanted
to be The Priest?
-I didn't think -- no.
They didn't really
know at the time.
But I was just so --
Everyone was really into it.
-Was everyone really into it?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but no.
I didn't wrestle kids.
I would wrestle dolls and stuff.
But I would say I was into,
like --
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I'd do moves --
-[ Laughing ] What?
-I'd do moves on, like,
my sister's Cabbage Patch
and stuff, yeah.
But that was my dream.
I was gonna be
a professional wrestler, and --
but I couldn't --
[ Light laughter ]
-No.
-I was too skinny.
-Annie and I have decided.
-Yeah.
-I'm not done --
-We decided...
-I'm not done explaining.
-...like five minutes ago.
-I think
we're done listening, Jimmy.
-No, no, no, no, no.
When I was a kid,
I dreamt of being a wrestler
called The Priest.
-Uh-huh.
-We, uh --
We're of the shared opinion,
Jimmy -- that's a lie.
♪♪
-It is a lie.
That is a lie.
You got it.
That's good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I thought maybe, I don't know.
I don't know.
I didn't know if --
I did, actually, at one point
want to be a priest.
-Right.
-So, I thought maybe a little
curveball on that truth
might have got in your head
a little bit.
Because you know me.
-You were gonna be a priest
and dress the same way
you described the wrestler.
-Right.
-Yeah, as a Chippendales.
-And that's when they
sent you right home.
-Same entrance!
[ Laughter ]
-They sent you right home
from seminary.
-Same entrance -- exactly, yes.
Annie, it is your turn to go.
Gosh, this is interesting.
All right.
One or two.
What do you think?
[ Crowd shouting ]
That's a mixed bag.
-I'm hearing "boo"
instead of "two,"
so I'm gonna do one.
-I didn't hear any boos.
All right, here we go.
-Just straight-up boos.
-This is good.
This is good.
-Okay.
I once licked Chris Martin's
sweat off my own hand.
[ Laughter ]
-At a concert?
You were at a concert?
-I was at a concert.
-If that's true,
that makes all three of us.
We've all done this.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, get --
-Get in line!
-All right.
So you were at a concert.
Were you in, like -- You had
good seats, I'm assuming.
-Great.
All access. All access.
I don't want to brag,
but all access.
-So is this --
Is this post-celebrity for you?
-This is pre-celebrity.
-Pre-celebrity.
-Yeah, like 10 years ago.
-Okay.
-You're a Coldplay fan.
-Yeah.
-Just throw some songs out.
What do you like?
-"Fix you."
-Yeah, sure. Of course.
-The one that goes...
♪ Whoa oh oh, oh oh ♪
[ Laughter ]
Um, uh -- "The Scientist."
-"The Scientist," okay.
-"The Scientist."
-"Yellow."
-Wow!
Deep cuts.
-"Court and Spark."
[ Laughter ]
-"Court and Spark"?
You're just making up words
at this point.
And how did you end up
touching Chris Martin?
-He -- I was actually
about three rows deep.
-Wow! And you still made it
to the stage.
-Well, it was the lurch.
It was, like, the --
-I love that you're coming down
like you're taller
than Chris Martin
when he's on stage.
You would be lurching up --
-He was not on stage.
-Oh!
-A twist.
-Your Honor.
A twist in the case.
-He was doing crowd work?
-He was doing --
[ Laughter ]
-I wouldn't call it crowd work.
-I think you do call it
crowd work.
-I think comedians do --
-No, he was doing
a stand-up set.
[ Laughter ]
-Crowd work.
-Trying some new material out.
-Yeah.
-So he's doing crowd work.
He's in there. He's going,
"Montreal, I love you guys.
You guys are the best."
And then he makes
eye contact with you?
-Nope.
-No. Wow.
But you were trying to force it.
-Yes.
-And you were
moving your eyes like,
"Hey, make eye contact with me."
-Indeed, yeah.
-And grabbed him.
And he pulled away and then you
had his sweat on your hand.
Now what -- your immediate
reaction was to lick it off?
-Yes.
-Gotcha.
So you were worried
something would happen.
Security would run over
and wipe the sweat off.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, before I was able to --
-Yeah, so you're like "I got to
get this into mouth fast."
-Who were you with?
-A bunch of my friends.
-And did they all freak
that you touched his hand?
-They looked at me with...
pride and disgust.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
And disgust after the lick
or pre-lick?
-After the lick.
-I thought they were disgusted
maybe the "how dare you" lurch?
-It was pre- and post-lick.
-Was there an awkwardness
after the fact that you hadn't
saved any licks for them?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
-That might be why
we don't speak anymore.
[ Laughter ]
-Sure.
-I'm gonna say, I think this
is a real licking.
-I think this is a real --
I'm picturing it the way
Winnie the Pooh goes at honey...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-...after he pulls it
from the jar.
Just like -- yeah.
So I'm with you.
I think this is a real thing.
-I wish --
Were you on the Jumbotron?
-No. I wish.
No.
-You wish?
But you were.
Whoa, you slipped!
Wait -- [ Laughs ]
Busted!
It did happen?
-It did happen.
-Yes!
-That's what
I'm talking about there!
Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was the giveaway, though.
That was a confession
right there.
-Really good work.
-I wish it was on Jumbotron,
because he's --
Really, you love Coldplay?
-Yeah.
-Who didn't?
-Who doesn't?
-But it was something
that was --
I didn't plan it.
It was just a voice in my head
that was like,
"You need to do it."
-Yeah.
-And just do it.
-And I did it.
And it wasn't --
You know, I love Coldplay
as much as the rest of us.
-No, I'm --
You like him a little bit more.
[ Laughter ]
-You licked his sweat.
I love that that's true.
Thank you guys for playing.
You're very good at this.
Seth Meyers, Annie Murphy!